so I hear you had a memorable moment
though um with a famous musician this is
the craziest story ever
is it so it's right it's right after you
got sober right oh I know yes so so on
my podcast literally one of one of the
things that I love is I get to not only
just talk to like people like Chris
Pratt and and Gwyneth and Oprah and just
the the biggies yeah that's good to talk
to people that I get to nerd out to that
I don't know like yawn winner created
the Rolling Stone he has a book out
that's great I had him on and I was
talking about when I got we're both
sober Jan and I I got sober 32 years ago
that's awesome thanks
[Laughter]
and so I was newly sober yeah and I was
backstage at a Rolling Stones concert
and Keith Richards said don't you come
back to the hotel and party with me
later and I I had this I was like okay
I'm either gonna party with Keith
Richards and not be sober yeah or I'm
gonna turn down Keith Richards to party
with on 20 whatever it is and I
remembered I didn't do it but it was
like one of those you because that's
hard because you know what though if you
turned on something that rad you knew
that you needed to make a change in here
yeah yeah you know that you know what
I'm saying and that's actually a good
that's a good point I felt really good I
felt like if I could do that when I was
going to be yeah right I'm like I always
get worried about stuff I've been
invited like certain things and I'm just
not like that rad I'm like I can't hang
with people so I'm like oh I'm busy I
always say I'm busy because I'm nervous
in those environments you have celebrity
intimidation factor it's not so much
that it's like it I think that like
maybe yes because
um I feel like they everybody feels like
we're all at some barbecue and we all
know each other and we all are supposed
to have everything in common and I'm
like what yeah we all have separate
friends outside of this world I know
it's weird but yeah and I'm like we're
all not cool we're gonna die it's like
build a bridge and get over it like it's
like we're all not that cool
[Music]
thank you
everybody
[Music]